My dad works for Vought.
Vought International.
Today's Heroes.
Tomorrow's Future.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
Turns out that the boys season four is
going to be doing a version of Spider-Man.
There is a version of Spider-Man Inside
the universe of the Boys of the comics.
I'll explain who that is.
His name is Webb Weaver.
Yet do picture
like a version of Bully Maguire,
Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man going for.
There's like,
the worst person you could possibly
imagine that has powers
just like Spider-Man.
I can already picture all the jokes
that they'll make about his organic
webbing and which holes
that that actually comes out of
If you're bringing new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We'll get more teasers
for the boys. Season four.
While they're doing the boys Gen V
episodes
and I will do some episode videos for that
when it does release later this year.
the weird thing about the Boys Universe
version of Spider-Man
is that he's only featured
briefly on the cover of The Boys.
Dear Becky Issues.
It was the very final issue.
The original Boys comic book by Garth
Ennis is meant to tell the story
of what happens to Hughie and Starlight,
like 12 years
after the events of the main story
with Butcher and the Boys versus
Homelander, the Seven and Vought.
No spoilers about how that story ends
because it sounds like
they're going to be blowing
past that pretty quickly
or stretching it out
big time over the next couple
seasons of the boys TV series.
The ending of the TV series
won't be exactly
like the ending of the comic book, though.
So if you have read
the ending of the comic book,
it will be a little bit different
the plot of that focuses on
Hughie finding Butcher's diary
in which he wrote about his wife Becky,
played by Shantel Vansanten on the TV show
and during his writings,
Butcher makes it clear
that Becky was essentially his conscience
that always kept him in
check for going too far.
And that's why when you see him during
the series, he's always going so hard
all the time, always crossing the line,
especially after her death.
She's not around anymore to keep him in
check.
Morally.
then the really messed up thing
that Hughie winds up learning
as he continues to read butcher's
diary is that he writes about wanting
to kill the fictional Becky that's
been living in his head after his death.
Like he hallucinates Becky
and metaphorically
wants to kill his conscience, so to speak,
so that he could defeat Homelander.
because he felt like
that was the only way he could beat him.
Because Homelander was so powerful
and so terrible,
he could only defeat him
by having no limits.
Webb, we've heard this boys
version of Spider-Man is featured
on a cover of one of these Dear
Becky issues, and it's
meant to be an homage to the classic
Marvel Amazing
Spider-Man issue number 316,
where Venom is taking out Spider-Man,
except in this case is Hughie with his
compound V powers taking out Webb Weaver.
And the other difference
with Hughie in the comics
is that he gets compound V powers
that are permanent in in the TV show
he just had the temporary compound
v powers zoom in enhanced notice
that his Spider-Man costume
on the cover here
looks about as Spider-Man like as you can
get without getting sued by Marvel.
Remember,
this was published a long time ago too.
But there's another image of him
that looks way more Spider-Man like here.
the funny thing, though, is that Webb
Weaver is only mentioned briefly
in the actual boys story, like he's
a relatively minor character
that you don't really see
that much of that.
There's a point earlier in the Boys
main storyline where Butcher goes
to the legend to find a Compound
V superhero that's big enough
that will convince Malory
to fund the boys team.
So this is happening way
before the events of the series
and the legend character
who's meant to be a parody of Stan Lee,
who just knows everything, has information
on all these different superheroes.
he also kind of
looks like J. Jonah Jameson in this scene.
The way he talks about Webb,
Weaver suggests that Butcher take down
where we were there, Spider-Man,
who they also call the hipster
it. That's about all you hear
or see of their version of Spider-Man.
You can see Gardena is trying
not to get sued by Marvel,
but clearly making a bunch of Spider-Man
parodies and jokes.
all the boys
characters are meant to be parodies
of Marvel and DC comic book characters
the upcoming Gen V TV show
is meant to be a parody of X-Men
with the School
for Gifted Children in Compound B Powers.
Clancy Brown's character
is meant to be a parody of Professor X,
But the whole idea is that
the university is a front for Vought
to find more compound these superheroes
that they can use to make more money off
of even though get token university
isn't from the comics, they're doing
a bit of an X-Men parody here.
There is an X-Men parody in the comic book
version of the Boys.
They're called the G-men Team, led by
an evil version of Professor X, basically.
Clancy Brown's professor
X type of character does have Compound
V's superpowers.
They didn't say exactly what they are.
But if he's meant to be a Professor
X parody,
then they might be mental abilities.
but basically the idea with the spinoff
here is they
have this university
called Goodluck in university God U,
which is meant to be a VOC
controlled school
that they used to pick through
all the compound bee babies
to find one that they can actually use to
make more money off of they're building.
The show is a little bit like X-Men,
like Xavier's School for gifted youngsters
in the Boys, Universal, X-Men in the Boys
universe, mixed with The Hunger Games
as they're all fighting for a chance
to join
the Seven in the whole Hunger
Games thing is the idea
that they're basically
killing each other off.
last person standing
gets a chance to join the seven.
the hoity in the boys universe is that
with very few exceptions across history,
parents will submit their children
for compound B testing
because at least
at the present day compound
the only really worked on children
when adults would take it,
it would just wind up making them explode.
recently.
They changed that
with the temporary compound.
B Like now
you see adults being able to take it
and it's a slightly different form
of the compound.
B but all the older children
and all the adults
who would have taken it
with the exception of Ryan and Homelander,
were basically dosed with compound B when
they were children as part of experiments
just to become part of
what's testing, to see if they could make
a better version of the formula
or if they could make a superhero
that they can make a ton of money off of
that was the real reason.
Like, hey, you submit your child,
you have a chance
to earn a lot of money off of them.
They could become
really rich as a superhero,
but really they just wanted them
as cannon fodder for their testing.
if they wound up developing really cool
or really marketable
useful superpowers,
that was just a bonus side effect.
the reason why Homelander was an
exception is because he was actually
artificially created in a lab
they took genetic material
from Soldier Boy and tried to refine
his DNA to make an even more powerful
superhero in that became homelander.
there is that across history.
You have all these different people
secretly submitting their children
for testing to get compounded
when they're babies.
the idea with tech night
is he's being played by Derek Wilson here
you see him in the trailer briefly.
It's like a short scene where he talks
about the rush, quote unquote,
I was hoping that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
would wind up being their tech night.
But he's actually playing a totally
different character during season four.
within the world of the comics.
He's meant to be a parody of both Marvel's
Iron Man and DC's Batman.
But the showrunner said,
for the purposes of the show
versus the comics,
they lean more in a Batman direction.
On the TV show.
something about them feeling
like Batman was more ripe for parody
than Iron Man's character,
even though they're both pretty ripe
for parody.
the whole idea with Batman and Iron Man,
they're similar in the both billionaires
that use their technology
to make themselves superheroes,
a bunch of gadgets, a bunch of armor,
instead of having natural compound
V abilities, like other superheroes
in the boys universe like Homelander
He's a huge character in the comics,
but he's super funny in a very,
very disturbing, messed up way.
Tech night as in technology like Iron Man,
Take Night has no natural powers.
All of his abilities come from the gear
that he invents, just like Iron Man
in night, as in The Dark Knight.
And in the past, he had a sidekick
named Lady who was a version of Robin
who also left him when he got older
to become a version of Nightwing
that they call Swing Wing on the series.
just like Iron Man and Batman.
He's super rich and has his own Batcave
full of weapons and machines that he uses.
They have released a couple in universe
sort of parody teaser trailer
videos for actual season four stuff
that they'll be covering
when the season begins.
This is one of those videos.
Good morning,
everyone. I'm Ashley Barrett.
Coming to you with an important update
on behalf
of our greatest hero
and our most loving father.
In the coming months,
Homelander will stand trial
for saving his son
from a vicious starlight loving thug.
An act of heroism.
Now somehow being branded a murder
make no mistake, Vought
and its shareholders stand fully behind
Homelander, and this will in no way
impact his status as captain of the Seven.
We have complete faith
in the American legal system
to get things right, like it always does.
For now,
keep him and Ryan in your thoughts
and in your prayers and be sure to post
with hashtag home free.
So he can see your support.
But this
is obviously them just joking about
what happened at the end of season
three with Homelander and killing that
dude that threw the can't.
Ryan the big surprise here
is that they're actually going to take
what happened at the end of season three
and they're going to hold Homelander trial
either at some point
at the very beginning of the season
or between season three and season four.
I'm not expecting them
to get too bogged down in this whole trial
for Homelander
at the beginning of season four.
Like they'll get into the main
part of the plot pretty quickly, probably.
Because there's no way that Homelander
would ever let himself be arrested
and be put in prison.
It'd be like trying to arrest Superman.
They had a lot of references to this
during the Man of Steel movie in Batman
v Superman.
With him
addressing the council here. look.
Imagine a version of this with Homelander.
Homelander would just be pretending that
there's no way
that he would bend over backwards
to try and make all these regular people
feel better about themselves.
There'd be, like, a brief hot second
where they tried to put him in cuffs,
and then he'd say, You know what?
I'm done with this. Screw this.
laser.
Everybody in sight.
They even had a teaser for that
in previous seasons
where he almost lost it
on an entire crowd of people
because he got so pissed off at them.
the other part of the joke here is that
Ashley is doing her very best.
Stan Edgar trying to spin
the news towards the benefit of Vought
in general, and Homelander
bravely trying to protect his son, Ryan,
against that vicious Starlight supporter.
all the thoughts and prayers, jokes
and then just the idea
that they're not going
to change anything of their day to day
because of what happened with Homelander.
is a bit of an evolution of what happened
during the events of season
three, where Homelander
just completely lost it on live
broadcast news, but it wound up making him
way more appealing to his base and way
less appealing to just a general audience
they've had this runner during the boys
seasons about the approval ratings
that each of the different superheroes
have, like the higher
the approval ratings
that they have amongst the public,
the more money
they earn from endorsements,
from the products
that they try to sell. Basically.
which is the way that Homelander sort
of measured how much people loved him.
And that's what he wanted. Like
he wanted people to love him.
so he's always obsessed with his quote
unquote, poll numbers in the public.
And that's what happened
after his big rant earning season three.
that spun into
an evolution of the whole idea
that he can do anything that he wants.
But now he actually kind of starts
to believe it
previously,
the idea that he was just kind of saying
that to himself,
I don't think he actually believed it.
He was slowly going crazier and crazier,
but now he's into like
full blown crazy territory
trying to drink his own Kool-Aid.
they also made
it seem like he had this weird moon
night thing going on where he had
this completely alternate persona
that he developed as a child to help him
survive just because of what it was like
growing up inside that special room,
quote unquote, that they kept him in.
remember when we got put in the bad room?
I got us through that.
They'll probably release
a couple of teasers for the boys
Season four during the Gen V episodes.
Of course, they'll do videos for it, so
be sure to enable alerts for my channels.
You don't miss any of that.
My. Asoka Episode five Video will post
after they release it.
Click here for that all at the link.
As soon as I post that and click here
for my new Aquaman
two trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.